продовжуємо уроки онлайн
веселої математики кумедної математики
від команди володимира зеленського за
останню краще ну влад ось ці ось по
фартузі, які у всі ви винні
закладалися до бюджету 71 мільярдів
гривень на субсидії на виплати субсидій
виплати людям у вигляді субсидій
через підвищення тарифів із високих
тарифів нова влада закладає бюджет
вона жила
36 мільярдів гривень за порошенка 71
президентському 36 і тут виникає відразу
кілька питань найголовніше що за
хрень відбувається і додаткові
зачекайте, і якщо ви знижуєте суму
субсидій які виплачуватимете
людям допомагати їм оплачувати чи тарифи
то варіантів лише кілька перший
варіант у нас виросло економіка люди
стали заробляти більше падає падає
вона туди типу там уже в жопі світу вже
економіка
а ви все це посилайтеся на вид на
пандемії на епідемію немає рідні не
вийде економіка сюди вниз може бути
у нас знизилися тарифи і тепер людям не
потрібні гроші не потрібно допомагати населенню
оплачувати тарифи є тарифи у нас
зростають расу там вже тарифи десь там
рік і ще зростатимуть і ще зростатимуть
і ще будуть рости і залишається тільки 3
варіант можливо у нас просто
зменшилася кількість населення та
тому не потрібно закладати до бюджету
субсидій що за хрень відбувається у
болоті
що це що це щось я також мушу
люди добрі верховна рада з чуйки на наш
займалася товаром ті ти відпочиваєш
я
я люди
підбивай